What's going on?
Welcome in.
Welcome everybody to another edition of Market Takes.
I know you could have been anywhere in the world,
but you're here with me and I appreciate that.
I'm your host,
Dion Rabo.
Thanks for tuning into Market Takes.
We are talking about the three most important things you need to be watching out for this
week and it is a big,
big week of earnings,
uh big tech,
lots of the market leaders reporting.
But of course,
we're gonna talk you through what's going on.
We've got earnings reports from meta Microsoft alphabet snap.
I'm talking three in Verizon,
Ebay,
Chipotle Intel for we're not going to talk about all those.
We're going to tell you which ones are really going to be the most impactful or have the biggest
impact on what's going on with the market this week.
We're also going to talk through the fed meeting the FO MC meets this week and they'll give us their decision on
Wednesday and we're going to talk about the second quarter US GDP report that could really
move markets in a big way that's out on Thursday.
So first things first we're talking through Big Tech and the earnings that we are expecting to see this week.
I want to put a chart up here on your screen to just show you what we're looking at in terms of the market performance.
Now that green line you see up there on your screen,
that's Metaform Facebook really leading things up over 100
36% so far year to date.
Microsoft also about 44% year to date.
Alphabet up more than 35%.
So all really leading and doing a lot more in terms of returns than the overall S and P
the S and P up about 20% a little less than that,
about 19.6% so far this year.
But you see the leadership has all come from Big Tech.
Everything else is kind of holding the S and P 500 down and the overall returns have
been pretty indicative of what we have seen from Big Tech.
So as those companies come out and report earnings this week,
they're gonna be really very highly watched because of just how much they have
outperformed and led the market.
And that has really happened all year.
We have seen the NASDAQ up big.
It's up 35% while the dow only up about 6%.
S and P 500 right between them about 19%.
So that number you're seeing right there,
that red line in the S and P doesn't look like much when you're comparing to those other big tech names that are
reported,
but we will hear from them this week and if their earnings disappoint,
well,
this big rally that we've seen that's got the S and P 500 up 20% year to date
could be in danger.
And this chart really just illustrating the importance of Big Tech in that rally.
And we're going to get those readings this week,
Tesla and Netflix last week.
They really disappointed in terms of guidance going forward and we saw the reaction,
the NASDAQ was down 2.5% on Thursday.
And then Friday,
we saw more losses on the NASDAQ on those tech on those,
uh on the tech side,
the NASDAQ we know is the tech heavy index.
Um really,
we've seen struggles.
The Dow has continued to do well up 10 straight days on Friday up right now for the
11th straight day.
This would be the longest streak since February of 2017 if the Dow ends high today.
But like I just showed you,
the Dow is only up 6% year to date.
It really is all about those tech names.
The earnings that we see this week could stop the rally in its tracks because we are expecting
or analysts are expecting a 9% decline in earning based on what we've seen in earnings
so far.
That would be the third straight negative quarter for earnings and it would be the most negative
quarter for earnings since Q two of 2020.
So going back three years since we've had earnings this negative and it's really
hard for a rally of 20% to continue where you've already got price to earnings ratios
stretch,
which is the historical measure of how much company stock prices versus what they're
actually selling versus what they're actually earning.
Right.
So the stock price compared to the earnings that a company is getting,
that's that pe ratio and it is pretty high right now.
Uh above both the five and 10 year trends on the S and P 500 the Dow and the NASDAQ.
So this really could be a big week in terms of those earnings that we get,
particularly from those big companies meta Microsoft alphabet,
those the big tech names,
the big tech leaders you're gonna want to watch for those,
all three of those are out this week.
Also snap also Intel have outperformed,
but those are the three big ones you want to watch next up.
We're going to talk about the fed decision that's almost been lost in all this earnings talk.
But the fed is coming out JP A K A JP A K AJ A K A
JP Money is going to be talking to us on Wednesday afternoon.
We'll be right here for market takes breaking down everything the chairman said,
didn't say all that.
Let's put a chart up here on your screen really fast to just show you where we are in terms of the
environment.
Now,
we are there on the right,
you see earnings up about right around 5% between five and 5.25%.
That is about as high as we've been in the last 20 years.
You see the last time,
uh,
rates were this high was back in 2008 and we all know what happened in 2008.
So when rates get this high,
usually the economy starts to get a little shaky.
The Fed is hoping to slow things down,
kind of cool things off and not have sort of those similar recession results that we have seen there.
But again,
this chart is illustrating where we are right now in terms of the rates environment and we are at a
very high level,
the FED is at restrictive territory,
it seems.
But the big question is,
is,
what is Jay Powell gonna say about that?
And that's going to determine whether we get a hawkish hike or a Dovish hike.
Listen,
the market is already pricing in a rate hike of 25 basis points at this fed meeting.
In fact,
when you look out at the fed funds futures market,
it's showing a 99.8% likelihood as of this morning as of right now,
when we're talking here,
uh,
that the fed is going to hike.
So the market is saying that's a foregone conclusion.
What matters is what Jay Powell says at that meeting,
whether he says,
you know what there's more to do,
we think there will be more rate hikes,
the fed at its last meeting projected two more rate hikes this year if they do
this one.
Now,
the big question is,
are they going to do another one?
They got to hike in September,
maybe November?
And what are they going to say,
to get the market ready for that or are they going to say,
hey,
you know,
we think we've done enough,
we think we need to pump the brakes on pumping the brakes and no more rate hikes anymore.
And so watch out for words like hold or we've done enough or policy is restrictive
enough that's gonna determine whether it's a Dovish or Hawkish rate hike and the
market is going to have a strong reaction to that one way or another.
So you're gonna want to watch that fed meeting.
You want to be,
you're gonna want to be with us here on market takes as we break that down at 4 p.m. eastern on
Wednesday.
Um,
and you'll want to be here.
You won't want to be anywhere else.
Last thing we've got coming this week is second quarter GDP and that's big because of
what this could really lock in,
what I've termed soft landing summer and I want to tell you why.
So we're gonna put a few charts up here on your screen to just kind of show you what we're looking for in terms of what
we've been looking at in terms of data.
First things first,
the US retail sales report and we talked about this a couple of weeks ago when this report
came out,
this is the year over year change and you see it just coming down there to where it's still positive,
it's still up higher than it was the year before,
but it's much lower.
It's under 2%.
The last reading we got in June was 1.5%.
And that just illustrating again,
you saw retail sales increases were very high.
People were making a lot more money that's not taking into account inflation and it's come down a
lot.
Another chart I want to put up here is the increase in jobs report though that non farm payrolls
report.
This is the increase in jobs we've seen uh month over month.
And so each month you've seen an increase in the number of jobs,
but that increase is slowing down last couple of months.
What we saw in June and then what we saw in April were some of the lowest we've seen since early
2021 in terms of jobs added.
So this chart again,
just illustrating that cool down,
that deceleration,
the slowing down.
And now I want to throw up the big one,
the most important chart in terms of data and that's that CP I inflation report.
I want to put that up there on your screen and you see just that very clear pattern of deceleration slow down.
Now,
this good illustrator,
this chart here illustrates what we have seen in terms of the overall data set coming
down and declining and illustrating.
Like I said,
just what I've called soft landing somewhere.
And that's because the things are coming down,
but they're still staying positive,
still seeing an increase.
You're still seeing good positive numbers up there on your screen,
but they're slower,
they're lower of the fed's 2% inflation goal.
And if we see Q two GDP coming in as expected,
which is 1.7% that could really lock this in.
Again,
another report showing that,
hey,
for the second quarter growth was positive,
it was solid but it wasn't too strong,
it wasn't too hot,
it wasn't inflationary.
It was just showing the US is chugging along growing as the fed wants to see.
So that's really what we're looking for in this week.
And you want to look out for all those things earnings.
You want to watch the Fed and you want to watch that Q two GDP number be right here for market takes
at 4 p.m. on Wednesday.
We wouldn't want to be anywhere else and listen,
that's gonna do it for us.
I am Dion Boen reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
Thanks so much for being with us and we hope you'll come back and do it with us next time.